[Music]
on this Monday night the risk of the
corona virus spreading through the air
the warning from hundreds of scientists
this really had been downplayed about
mounting evidence of airborne exposure
in indoor spaces with poor ventilation
borders screening under scrutiny why of
tens of thousands of foreigners been
allowed into Canada during the pandemic
Beijing's travel advisory the warning to
Chinese citizens about coming to Canada
and a soulful Canadian talent silenced
this world's gone crazy
Cobin 19 claims a beloved and young
Broadway star
global national with Donna freezin
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin with a hot topic among experts
in infectious disease and air quality
the airborne transmission of the novel
coronavirus 239 scientists from 32
countries have signed a paper saying we
appeal to the medical community and to
the relevant national and international
bodies to recognize the potential for
airborne spread of kovat 19 the concern
is about microscopic droplets that
linger in the air and can travel further
than two meters and could be infectious
especially in enclosed spaces with poor
ventilation crystal commencing on the
evolving evidence of airborne
transmission the virus that causes kovat
19:00 travels in microscopic droplets
and a large number of scientists around
the world want more attention put on
those very tiny particles that can stay
circulating in a room there's a lot of
evidence that suggests that airborne
transmission can be part of the
mechanism involved and that this really
had been downplayed the director of the
southern Ontario center for atmospheric
aerosol research is one of more than 200
experts calling on the World Health
Organization to acknowledge the issue
and advocate for better air quality
systems dr. Michael garden remains
concerned about transmission even if
requirements for better air filtration
systems were mandated bars and
restaurants are perfect scenarios for
that they're loud you're right up close
with somebody yelling in their face you
may be half drunk so you're not paying
attention to what you're doing all of
that makes it highly likely that this
could spread if you were to increase the
ventilation to deal with airborne that's
not going to deal with that face to face
that face to face close exchange is
believed to be how the majority of
infections occur that's why people are
told to keep their distance wear masks
and to wash their hands but the authors
of this article are putting pressure on
the w-h-o saying more needs to be done
the w-h-o responded saying we are aware
of the article and are reviewing its
contents with our technical experts as
more people head out
back to work Greg Evans wants them to be
aware of their environment how much of
the breath is what we call we breath or
exhaled breath in the room so what is
the potential for exposure to occur if
there is somebody who's infected in that
space the scientists concerned about
aerosol transmission say it's not about
creating fear but about giving the
public all of the information crystal de
Manson Global News London
it is well-established the novel
coronavirus can spread through large
droplets expelled when an infected
person coughs sneezes speaks or sings
they can spread it up to two meters or
more depending on their size that's why
we have the two meter physical
distancing rule and why we encourage
wearing masks when that's not possible
this latest research says micro droplets
are a potential risk to their just 5
microns in size a single grain of table
salt is about 100 microns micro droplets
or aerosols can remain aloft longer and
spread further diseases like measles
chicken pox and tuberculosis can be
spread through airborne transmission and
the experts behind this latest research
admit the evidence for all the steps in
Kovach 19 micro droplet transmission is
incomplete but they do say simple
measures like good ventilation fresh air
circulation and avoiding overcrowding
our precautions worth taking well there
are lots of things we still don't fully
understand about Kovach 19 and now there
are fresh questions about the origins of
the virus it's widely believed the virus
first emerged in China in late 2019
after jumping from animals to humans now
an epidemiologist at Oxford University
says there's evidence the virus may have
been dormant around the world long
before the first confirmed case that
theory is based in large part on
evidence from Italy Brazil and Spain
that found traces of the virus in
wastewater samples as early as March
2019 9
the Oxford scientist says experts
investigated coving nineteen's origins
should consider that it may have lain
dormant around the world and emerged
when the environmental conditions were
right for it to thrive the United States
is on track to shatter
another kovin 19 record as infections
they're surged across the country nearly
three million Americans have now tested
positive for kovat 19 and that number is
ticking up at an alarming rate
according to Reuters 16 states broke
records for new cases in the first five
days of July in Florida more than 10,000
people tested positive yesterday alone
officials in Miami are now reimposing
some restrictions though as Jackson
prosecco reports many Americans still
aren't grasping where this could be
headed this is exactly what health
experts feared packed beaches and
parties over the 4th of July weekend as
kovat 19 cases surged in the majority of
states right now the virus has the upper
hand throughout much of America most of
America defiance now seems to be the
only national strategy in the u.s. in
Florida which sets several daily records
for new cases over the weekend the
governor insisted everything is fine
because most of the thousands of newly
infected are young of you're under 40
and you don't have significant
comorbidities you know the fatality rate
for this is it's pretty close to zero
that echos a weakened claim from
President Donald Trump we show cases 99%
of which are totally harmless who has
alternated between ignoring the virus
and suggesting Americans should just
live with it to the dismay of those
who've already suffered the worst of it
and now the country is suffering because
of the President and it's time for him
to change course it's time for the
president to actually tell the truth the
US has the highest number of total cases
deaths and daily new infections of any
country on earth and has still not
reached a consensus on measures like
masks and physical distancing I think
the world is looking at us as a leader
and kovin 19 the White House continues
to argue there's only one indicator that
matters
the death rate it's down from its peak
that likely won't last
hospitals are already overwhelmed in a
growing number of states getting used to
surges in hospitalizations and
deaths is not something that any of us
could really get used to and nor should
we really try to get used to this in a
sign of where it may all be headed Miami
has decided to roll back on reopening as
cases their surge shutting restaurants
gyms and clubs for a second time
Jackson Costco Global News Washington
India is rising in the ranks as one of
the worst hit countries in the world
today it surpassed Russia becoming the
country with the third most cases after
the US and Brazil more than 24,000
people tested positive in 24 hours
bringing India's total to nearly 700,000
a temporary hospital with capacity for
10,000 patients is now open in New Delhi
to help deal with the surge in cases in
Australia authorities are taking extreme
measures after an outbreak in the
Melbourne area as of Tuesday night the
borders between the country's two most
populous states Victoria and New South
Wales will be closed and soldiers will
be posted along state lines to prevent
anyone crossing the last time this
happened was a hundred years ago during
the Spanish flu pandemic Canada's
greatest threat from Kovach 19 is south
of the border where sealed off from the
alarming spike in cases in the US but
only as long as the us-canada border
remains closed to all but essential
travel that agreement is set to expire
July 21st and today Prime Minister
Justin Trudeau says he is not travelling
to the u.s. he's just turned down an
invitation to visit the White House on
Wednesday our Ottawa bureau chief
Mercedes Stevenson joins me Mercedes
bring us up to speed Donna Prime
Minister Justin Trudeau will not be
attending that summit in Washington DC
despite lingering concerns about
potential aluminum tariffs for Canada
instead Justin Trudeau will remain here
for cabinet meetings and a rare sitting
of parliament not to mention that
much-anticipated fiscal snapshot but
senior government sources did
acknowledge concerns about kovat 19 and
a potential 14 day quarantine upon his
return also played a role in the
decision not to go
the border is a concern not only for the
Prime Minister but for many Canadians as
they watch kovat 19 cases surging in the
United States and while the border has
been closed since March 21st
international air travel has doubled
over the last two months the number of
passengers arriving from the US and
other global destinations has increased
from 15 thousand people a week in April
to 30 thousand a week in June since May
25th alone 135,000 air travelers have
arrived in Canada sixty-six thousand of
those travelers are not Canadian
permanent residents or Canadian citizens
so what are those 66,000 people doing in
Canada the Canada Border Services Agency
couldn't give Global News a breakdown
but said all 66,000 are considered
exempted foreign nationals which
includes essential workers like medical
workers and temporary foreign workers
here to labor on farms but one
infection-control expert at the
University of Toronto finds it hard to
believe that that sudden spike is all
essential workers and wants a clearer
definition we have a national
conversation about the concern isn't
just about Americans and international
travelers who come here it's also about
Canadians who come home but ignore
self-isolation rules clearly some people
who say that they will be self isolating
but earned and they are putting all of
us at risk and this is not acceptable
dr. Colin furnace warns that the closed
border may be the new normal for as much
as a year warning that the warm summer
weather has given many a false sense of
security
getting away with a lot but when
September comes and the weather starts
to cool down people start to move inside
more maybe a little bit less vigilant
after a few months with very little
community spread we might really be
facing a catastrophe Donna according to
Health Canada contact with a traveler
accounts for only 1% of Canadian kovat
19 cases and on top of that
international air travel even with the
recent spike is still down by about 95%
from
was at this time last year but there is
still pressure to reopen the border
nearly 30 congressmen and Congresswomen
signed a letter to the Trump
administration advocating for an end to
the constant 30-day extensions at the
border closure and saying it's time for
a phased plan for reopening Dona
Mercedes Stevenson in Ottawa thank you
Prince Edward Island was until Saturday
Kovac 19 free for more than two months
and now has five active cases all of
them connected to a man who traveled to
Nova Scotia one of these cases a young
man traveled to Nova Scotia and spent
time with another man in his 20s who had
recently arrived from the United States
this new cluster of cases is a strong
reminder that we are still susceptible
to Cove at 19 and that we cannot become
complacent
she says ten close contacts of those new
cases have all tested negative and are
now in isolation for 14 days but that
screening at the PEI border will remain
in place for the foreseeable future
clear view AI the us-based company
behind controversial facial recognition
software says it's pulling out of Canada
and will no longer work with the RCMP
the company's last remaining client in
this country the technology has been
labeled invasive and Canadian regulators
are investigating whether clear views
artificial intelligence technology
breaks privacy laws Clearview AI came
under fire earlier this year after a
number of police services in Canada
confirmed they had used the technology
which cross-references images of people
against billions of photos taken from
the internet without consent there are
new details tonight on the intruder who
rammed his truck into the gates of
Rideau Hall in Ottawa court documents
revealed a man charged with 22 offences
after breaching the grounds of the
residents of both the prime minister and
the Governor General is accused of
uttering a threat or conveying a threat
to cause death or bodily harm to Prime
Minister Trudeau according to
information sworn by an RCMP officer he
also had loaded firearms with them the
court documents reveal Canadian Forces
member Corey hirin reservists and the
Canadian Rangers had an m14 rifle which
is prohibited in
though he did have a license for it he
also had two shotguns and an
unregistered revolver it's alleged he
got out of his vehicle and was heading
for Trudeau's residence when he was
intercepted and eventually arrested by
police in New York City a woman who
called the police claiming a black man
was threatening her in Central Park has
now been charged with filing a false
report
please don't come close to me please
please call the cops in May Amy Cooper
drew widespread condemnation after this
video went viral it shows her calling
911
by an african-american man his name is
Christian Cooper and he was
bird-watching in the park he simply
asked her to put her dog on a leash
Ezra's required in that area he didn't
threaten her but did record her rant and
posted it on social media she lost her
job after this and temporarily had to
give up her dog tensions between Beijing
and Ottawa escalate coming up why China
is telling its citizens don't go to
Canada
the UK is imposing sanctions on some of
the individuals and organizations behind
some of the worst human rights abuses in
modern times they include people from
Russia Saudi Arabia Myanmar and North
Korea
they'll have their UK assets frozen and
are banned from entering the country to
those who abused their power to inflict
unimaginable suffering we will not look
the other way you cannot set foot in
this country and will cease your blood
drenched ill-gotten gains if you try
some of those affected are senior Saudi
intelligence officials accused of being
involved in the killing of journalist
Jamal khashoggi and Istanbul and Russian
authorities implicated in the death of
Sergei Magnitsky a lawyer who died in
Moscow prison after exposing a tax fraud
scheme involving Russian officials the
British sanctions framework follows the
2012 u.s. Magnitsky Act China is now
warning its citizens to exercise caution
when traveling to Canada today a
spokesperson for China's foreign
ministry said Canada has seriously
violated international law and basic
norms governing international relations
and grossly interfered in China's
internal affairs and it warns Chinese
citizens in Canada could be subject to
what it calls frequent violent actions
from law enforcement still ahead pregame
problems why sports are still struggling
to restart in the pandemic
plenty of sports fans are waiting for
the games to begin again well keeping
the players and their families safe
tonight some Toronto Blue Jays players
who were in close contact with the
player tested positive for kovat 19 are
stuck in Florida and as Eric Sorenson
reports the NHL is making a final pitch
on how to get back on the ice safely
this really will be home to the Toronto
Blue Jays the team will practice and
live right here for now staying at the
Marriott hotel attached to the Rogers
Center baseball field a giant bubble to
keep out cove at 19 the players flew
back to Toronto Sunday night fun and
quite exciting that they are going to
reopen fans are looking forward to
baseball the club was training in
Dunedin Florida till the spread of the
virus forced several teams to close down
operations many ball clubs are now
practicing at home but also isolating
from the outside world outside of
Florida Toronto could be a major North
American hub for sports this summer if
the Blue Jays play their games at home
here it means other major league teams
will come to Toronto and then there's
Hockey Toronto could be a hub for 12 NHL
playoff teams all having to isolate our
bubble in this city that would bring
Sidney Crosby and other Eastern
Conference stars to Toronto 12 Western
teams could play in Edmonton the league
and Players Association have now agreed
on protocols that will be voted on this
week some people aren't thrilled so many
sports teams could come to Toronto one
tweeted there is zero reason that sports
should be putting a single Torontonian
at risk others aren't so worried it'll
be good to have the boys home
we love the Jays we want to see them
here we want to see them safe healthy
health officials say teams will be
separated from the public as long as
bubbles are maintained you know one for
hockey and one for the baseball players
then the risk to the public is minimal
if anything still a cloud of uncertainty
hangs over pro sports Major League
Soccer's opening match this Wednesday
between Vancouver and Dallas was
postponed when six Dallas players tested
positive the NBA is going ahead with its
massive bubble and Disney World
teams are expected in Orlando this week
protocols are extensive says this former
Toronto Raptor become so frustrating and
overwhelming at times because you just
never thought you'll be in a situation
such as something like this with covert
19 lurking major sports leagues are
taking tentative steps towards a
hurry-up start to their seasons Eric
Sorensen Global News Toronto up next a
Canadian Broadway star dies of Koba 19
soundtracks like this from the film the
mission made composer Ennio Morricone
legendarium the maestro as he was known
was 91 years old he broke his femur ten
days ago and died this morning in a Rome
Hospital Marconi created music that set
the mood for dozens of big movies from
spaghetti westerns like the good the bad
and the ugly and Quentin Tarantino's the
hateful eight for which he won an Oscar
well there's no soundtrack for this next
story though it's a tragedy worthy of
lots of attention and it's a cautionary
tale a Canadian actor a Broadway star
and a father of one-year-old son has
died of complications from the corona
virus Nick Cordero was sick for months
much of that spent in a coma his lungs
ravaged by the disease
Mike Joe lay on Cordero's life and death
everyday at 3 p.m. nick Cordero's wife
would sing his song laughing and dancing
with their son Elvis before returning to
the hospital to hold the Broadway stars
hand doctors told a man to clewd four
times her husband wouldn't make it and
for 95 days he bucked the odds you just
feel like you're in this momentum of
going around around around like a
hamster wheel and I just want to get us
out of the hamster wheel he had a leg
amputated a pacemaker implanted he even
woke from a coma but doctors couldn't
repair the damage kovat 19 did to his
lungs
and no amount of Broadway magic could
help the 41 year old either behind the
scenes we are just we're just devastated
and our hearts are broken our hearts are
broken cordero honed his baritone voice
in his hometown of Hamilton Ontario
it's where he learned to love the stage
but it wasn't long before he needed more
he was one of the very few of us that
actually took the leap and and went for
it and then made it he starred in
bullets over Broadway and while he was
nominated for a Tony he won the
affection of his cast mate and future
wife Amanda but no matter how Broadway
his life became he always had time for
Hamilton Nick is Nick and Nick will
always be Nick and people just loved I
mean it was great because he would come
home and he would have stories to tell
people and and you know all of us
theater nerd theater kids all looking up
to him being like oh my god what's it
like in the you know where where we all
want to be he was there and he did it
yeah he did it and when the curtain once
again Rises on Broadway after the
pandemic that took his life is over no
doubt the lights will dim for him to
microlight Global News Toronto and
that's global national for this Monday
I'm donor Friesen tonight Air Canada is
dildo Newfoundland and Labrador I've
been there got the t-shirt thanks for
watching